>>Luiz Barroso: My name is Luiz Barroso and
thank you for coming here and helping me welcome
Jonathan Koomey to Google today.
Many of us here have known Jon for a very
long time because Google and many of us share
the passion for understanding the impact of
computing technology in the world.
Jon's been working on this for a very long
time.
For those of you who are not in the audience
and are from Google and, therefore, are tired
on knowing this, Google has cared about the
energy efficiency and our impact on the environment
for quite awhile.
I believe Google's been carbon neutral since
2007.
We have, by now, invested nearly a billion
dollars in renewable energy products and we
have been able to share with the industry
and the academic community some of our findings
in how we are able to achieve a very high
efficiency in our daily centers as well.
Now, Jon has been very influential figure
in this field at least over the past decade
or so and even though his very data driven
approach may be considered a little bit old
fashioned these days-
[Laughter]
>>Barroso: given how quickly some of our political
candidates divorce themselves from factual
data.
>>Barroso: Jon really likes data and he likes
principled analysis.
Some of you may be familiar with some of the
studies he did that are closer to what we
do here at Google estimating energy consumption
of servers and data centers.
To both studies, the one in 2007 as well as
one, another one last year, are very widely
cited and respected as good data points in
this area.
Jon is here today to talk about computing
energy efficiency and you see the title, The
Computing Trend That Will Change Everything.
After many years at Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratories he has just joined, let me make
sure I say that correctly, Steyer, The Steyer
Taylor Center for Energy Policy and Finance
at Stanford University as a research fellow.
He has co authored dozens of research publications
and has been the single author of at least
two books one of which is recent and is here
right now; "Cold Cash, Cool Climate."
We happen to have copies of the book here
available for purchase after the talk and
Jon will be happy to sign them.
Please help me in welcoming Jon Koomey.
[Applause]
>>Jon Koomey: Luiz, thank you very much for
that gracious introduction.
So in the technology industry there's always
a lot of loose talk about revolutionary change.
I’m convinced that we're on the cusp of
a revolution worthy of the name and it's one
driven by the energy efficiency of computing
and communications.
Those trends and the efficiency of these devices
are enabling a proliferation of gadgets that
are cheap, that are smart, that are small,
that are connected and that are so low powered
that often times they can scavenge the energy
they need from ambient energy flows.
So as an example of what's becoming possible,
this is a company called Proteus Biomedical.
They've created a one cubic millimeter device
that goes inside a pill.
This pill, in its current carnation, is a
placebo pill that's taken along with other
medications.
When it hits your stomach, the digestive juices
in your stomach allow it to generate just
enough power to send a signal to a patch that
you have on your skin near your stomach and
that then tells the doctor when you took your
pills.
Now, for most of us it's not a problem to
remember when to take your pills but there
are large classes of populations where you
actually need to know this and for certain
kinds of diseases this is very, very important.
So this is a tiny thing, it uses very little
power, it scavenges the energy it needs from
your internal workings and it will transform,
ultimately as more sensors are added to this
kind of device, it will transform the way
we understand the human body.
So this is just one of many examples, I'm
in the process of compiling case studies of
different technologies and business models
that are enabled by the trends that I'm gonna
talk about for the rest of this discussion.
So the research question that I wanted to
answer was how has the energy efficiency of
computing changed over time?
At the end of the talk I'll discuss what I
think some of the implications are of that
and I'll ask for your help because all of
you have lots of interesting ideas that I
don't know about on technologies and business
models that are potentially relevant.
So if you have examples for me, by all means,
come up after the talk or send me an email.
So everyone knows about Moore's Law.
It's not a law in the physical sense it's
an empirical observation about economics of
chip production.
In 1965, he looked at, Gordon Moore looked
at the trends in the production of chips and
he found that the component density was doubling
roughly every year.
In 1975, he revisited that because of changes
in the economics, the trend moved to doubling
every two years and that trend in density
has helped for more or less the last 30 plus
years.
Now it's a characterization of the economics
of chip production not physical limits and
it's often imprecisely cited.
So for those of you who are interested in
understanding how this, the law as it's precisely
stated, evolved over time, there's a great
article by Mollick in 2006 in the IEEE Annals
that I heartily recommend.
So this is Moore's original graph and on the
Y axis, we have the relative manufacturing
cost per component, on the X axis the number
of components per integrated circuit.
Over time each of these curves is a snapshot
in a particular year and the minimum point
of this curve is the point of lowest cost
production.
As you can see over time the cost per component
goes down and from the progress in the minima
of these curves we get, what's now known as
Moore's Law.
[Coughing in background]
>>Jon Koomey: This has led to more popular
presentations of this.
This is a graph most of you have seen, number
of transistors per chip over time and this
is from data from James Larus.
It's from '71 to 2006, the doubling time is
about every 1.8 years for transistor density.
So originally when I started looking into
this question of transit efficiency I wanted
to replicate some work I had done for servers
where I looked at energy efficient-, energy
use, cost and performance.
In the research for this later work I actually
found a great article by Bill Nordhaus who's
an economist at Yale.
And his, most of his academic work is actually
in the climate area, he's done a great deal
of work on the economics of climate mitigation
but he's also an aficionado of the history
of computing.
And he compiled a long term trend in performance
and cost for computing that I was able to
build upon.
So once I found that work I realized that
it didn't make sense for me to go into the
cost side but instead I wanted to focus just
on energy and performance.
So I started looking into this, this was my
calculation from two computers that I had
at my house that had some data on the cost
of the old IBM PC XTAT and the cost of ENIAC.
So this was kind of exploratory.
It looks, more or less, like a straight line
on a log plot.
That's fine, that's cost, calculations per
second, per dollar of per purchase cost.
Then I made this graph, computations per kilowatt
hours, similar sort of picture.
But it was this graph that really sent me
down the path to understanding what was going
on with efficiency of computing.
So my friends at Lawrence Berkeley Lab who
run their super computer group, they had some
estimate data on the power use performance
of their devices.
So they had a Cray-1 back in the day, these
Nurkse machines are a set of gradually more
powerful super computers that they had installed
at the lab and that, that really peaked my
interest and I said, "Okay, maybe if I fill
in data in this graph I'll learn something
interesting and important."
So the method that I used here was to focus
on the peak performance of the computers and
the energy use at peak performance.
So number of computations per hour at full
load divided by the measured electricity consumption
at full load, so full load, full computing
load, maximum performance.
So this says nothing about the machine powering
down this is all about the active performance
at highest output as well as the energy use
at that period.
So I, when you see computations per kilowatt
hour, that's what this means.
Now the Nurkse data, it turns out I didn't
actually end up using those data cause they're
not measured.
So every point on the graph that I will show
you is measured data for electricity consumption
and performance that's been normalized to
Nordhaus' database or taken directly from
it for purposes of the performance side.
So there's a lot of different published data
on power use.
There's a great set of reports that was done
for the Office of Naval Research by Weik in
'55, '61 and '64.
That was back in the day when you could actually
count the number of computers there were and
there were dozens or low hundreds.
I also visited various archives and people
who had old computers.
In general, when I was doing these measurements
the computer was fully utilized for portables.
There are a few in the database I subtracted
out the screen power.
Not it's an important caveat, all of you know
this, but actual performance trends with real
software in use are not necessarily the same
as performance trends as measured from benchmarks
and those are not the same as transistor trends.
There's often a lot of confusion in the popular
discussion of this, it's important to state
that up front.
Now in the PC era, starting with microprocessors,
performance per computer doubled more or less
every year and a half.
So this is something that I call the popular
interpretation of Moore's Law, when you talk
about Moore's Law with most folks that's what
they say.
But Moore, to my knowledge, never talked about
performance just density of components.
This is a graph of computations per second
per computer, the maximum computing output
for a variety of different devices over time.
Most of these data come from the Nordhaus
work.
There's several dozen more that I added to
the database but you can see a clear upward
trend as you'd expect.
You also see this interesting result here.
In 1960 around the time of the shift to transistors,
you start to see a bit of a jump in performance
and we'll see that again in the efficiency
curve as well.
So I did a variety of measurements on different
computers.
I visited the Microsoft computer archive which
is a temperature and humidity controlled vault
that has many old computers including an original
Mac, Fat Max, original IBM PCs and a variety
of other devices.
I crawled under the desks of some of my colleagues
at Lawrence Berkeley National Lab because
they had dozens of computers that I could
easily get access to.
My in-laws are photographers, they had some
high powered computers as well and then we'll
see in a second, Erik Klein is a history of
computing buff and he had a variety of computers
in his own archives that I couldn't find anywhere
else.
The Computer History Museum here in Mountain
View, I'm sure all of you have visited there,
if you haven't it's an amazing resource and
there's still lots of online activity from
people who are aficionados of old computers
and, so, people who actually understand how
vacuum tubes work were very patient in educating
me as to the subtleties.
So does anyone know this computer?
You recognize this?
>>male #1: Altair
>>Jon Koomey: Altair 8800.
This was a kit computer.
It appeared on the cover of "Popular Electronics"
in 1976 and it sold 10s of thousands of units.
It was the first recognizable personal computer.
It looks a lot different than what we're used
to nowadays.
How about this one?
>>male #2: Osborne.
>>Jon Koomey: Osborne, yes.
This is what passed for a portable computer.
[Laughter]
>>Jon Koomey: I'd say luggable is more like
it.
The screen is about four inches, diagonally
it's a monochrome screen and you have to plug
it in.
So it was really for people who were using
it on site and they had power, they needed
to carry a computer with them.
This one's obvious, the old Apple 2.
It brings back memories, I did my senior thesis
in college on an Apple 2E.
So this is just, this is Erik Klein, he has
a garage full of old computers, some of which
I just showed you.
So this is the bottom line result from that
analysis.
The efficiency of computing defined as the
number of computations you can do at full
load divided by the kilowatt hours used during
that same period has doubled more or less
every year and a half since the 1940s.
So longer than Moore's Law starting with vacuum
tube computers.
This results in about a hundred fold improvement
every decade in the efficiency of computing
and, in essence, this trend enabled the existence
of laptops and smart phones.
So for the statistics whizzes in the audience,
a good correlation here R squared at .98 for
all computers, .97 for PCs, these statistics
are good as well.
Erik Brynjolfsson is a friend at MIT.
I ran my regressions past him just to make
sure I had done it right and he said, "Yeah,
it all looks good and damn I wish my regressions
looked like that, too."
[Laughter]
>>Jon Koomey: but doubling time for computations
per kilowatt hour, 1.6 years or so for all
computers, 1.5 years for PCs and slightly
fast improvement in efficiency during the
vacuum tube era.
There's a big jump, as you can see, when we
switch from tubes to transistors.
So typically for, on a per switch basis, transistors
are 10 to 20 times more efficient than tubes
but what you see here is a more, is about
a 2 order of magnitude, maybe a little more
jump in the efficiency.
What I think is going on there, it's not just
having more efficient transistors but it's
also innovation in the way people were using
and designing these devices that led to an
increase in performance.
So not as many devices in the discrete transistor
era but then, of course, by the time we got
to microprocessors, there were more computers
to measure.
So here are some summary implications, the
things you do to improve performance, at least
over the period I analyzed, almost invariably
improve computations per kilowatt hours.
So for transistors you make them smaller,
you have shorter distance from the source
to the drain, you have fewer electrons in
the transistor that all reduces power use.
For tubes, it's a similar story.
You make them smaller, they have lower capacity
and slower currents that all reduces power
use as well.
The trends that I'm describing here make mobile
and distributed computing ever more feasible.
So I you think about it in terms of a device
that has a battery, the battery life improves
100 fold per decade at constant computing
power.
So this is one example of the result of this,
these trends.
So this is installed base of personal computers,
laptops and desktop.
In 2009, for the first time according to IDC
data, laptops outsold desktops.
So this is, this graph shows installed base
but just to give you the perspective here,
laptops outsold desktops in 2009 and they
will continue to do so going forward.
So this trend toward more and more laptops
in the installed base is only going to continue
and increase.
This is another interesting example, this
is the full belly, sorry, the big belly trash
compactor and this is an example of both computing
and communications reducing environmental
impacts in other parts of a business process.
So these are installed typically in parks,
places where a truck needs to go around and
pick up the garbage and first off it compacts
the trash five times.
So right off that's five times fewer trips
for the big garbage trucks but it also, it
sends a text message when it's full.
So it's actually better than an 80 percent
improvement.
And it generates its own power from a photovoltaic
panel on top.
So self powered device would not be possible
without very efficient information technology
as well as efficient compacting.
So this is an economic and environmental home
run, clearly.
What it does is it allows you to substitute
bytes for atoms and any time you can do that,
almost invariably, that improves environmental
performance.
So here's another example.
I'm going to visit these folks on the 17th
of September, Josh Smith, at University of
Washington, used to be at Intel.
He's designed sensors that scavenge energy
from stray radio and TV signals.
So in active mode these are using 60 microwatts
for similar kinds of devices there are other
possible power sources so light, heat, motion,
bodily fluids as we talked about.
But, clearly, by the time you start getting
useful computing work being conducted at the
microwatt level, you are starting to imagine,
you can start to imagine applications that
we could never ever do before and that's ultimately
what I think the source of the revolution
will be.
So, other implications here, there's a lot
of focus on big data but Erik Brynjolfsson
at MIT likes to talk, instead, about nano
data, data that's focused on specific transactions
and specific individuals and our ability to
do very detailed monitoring of transactions
and characteristics of people and institutions
will actually give us great insight invisibility
into what's going on there in a way that we
never could before.
We'll have ever more precise control of processes,
we'll have better ability to do real time
analysis, what's actually happening in the
world and it will, of course, enable the internet
of things to come about.
So bottom line on the implications here will
have better matching of energy services demanded
with those supplied.
So people always talk about the end of Moore's
Law and Luiz and I were talking earlier about
the end of Dennard's Scaling, most folks when
they talk about that, they talk about it from
the perspective view saying, "Here's our technology
as we have it now.
We're seeing real problems in how we implement
this going forward and increased density is
increased performance.
What are we gonna do to fix that?"
I'm gonna take a different view here using
historical perspective here.
Back in 1985, Richard Feynman the physicist,
he calculated a theoretical limit to the efficiency
of computing.
Now he did it by making an assumption.
He said, "Let's assume a three atom transistor."
If I do that, using my computation wizardry,
I can come up with if the ultimate physical
limit for computing.
He did that.
I plotted it on this curve, so here's that
same graph that we saw.
If you were to extrapolate the trend out to
that physical limit, it would take us about
three decades, so to 2041 or so.
What this graph tells you, and it's the same
story you're getting from the folks worried
about Dennard scaling, is that sometime in
the next few decades we are going to have
to radically change how we do computing.
So this take comes at it from the theoretical
limit perspective rather than looking at our
current technology.
Now, one interesting little clever tidbit,
earlier this year, researchers at Purdue,
the university not the chicken company, and
the University of New South Wales created
a reliable one atom transistor.
It uses electron energy levels within one
atom to do switching.
Now, it runs at liquid helium temperatures.
[Laughter]
>>Jon Koomey: But what it says is that if
we're, you know, if we, again, can radically
change how we do this computing then there's
a potential for much higher efficiencies.
But, again, we're gonna have to change what
we're doing.
So there are some big unanswered questions
here.
One, to me is, are there innovations either
in software and hardware that will allow us
to substantially exceed this historical rate
of change in efficiency of computing?
Conversely, what road blocks might get in
the way and prevent the trends from continuing
after this current innovation pipeline of
the next five to ten years is exhausted?
And then, of course, what do we do after we
reach Richard Feynman's theoretical limit
or the one atom transistor limit?
Obviously, you know, I don't have the answer
to those questions but I wanna summarize what
I think some of these, the big picture, implications
are.
So, it's not just about computing efficiency.
Low power is actually more important than
efficiency.
You can make slightly less efficient devices
that are really low power that perform useful
computing service, you can put them in places
like pills or in every device here giving
an IP address to the lights and other things
that don't need to be connected by wiring.
The revolution that I'm talking about is being
driven by a confluence of trends.
So it's the efficiency of computing but also
the efficiency of communications and the efficiency
of sensors.
So as we get MEMS devices that can do sensing
at very low power levels then you get all
sorts of interesting things that we couldn't
do before, and then, of course, efficiency
of controls.
As soon as you starting getting these really
low power devices energy storage becomes really
important and the energy harvesting becomes
important as well.
In most of these devices, the bulk of the
electricity use is actually in idle mode.
So the active power is not the most critical
thing in many cases, it's actually how fast
can you put the device to sleep and how low
can you make the power use go?
So the engineering challenges are different
from building the fastest computer at its
peak output, that's a very different set of
engineering challenges than building one that
is elegantly simple, that powers down quickly,
that has very low idle power, it's a kind
of elegant simplicity that's a little different
than the focus on ever more powerful active
mode performance.
So let me just summarize results, here, so
we leave time for questions.
In the PC era, the performance per computer
doubled every year and a half.
The efficiency of computing also doubled every
year and a half during that period.
So those things are connected.
From ENIAC to the present, computations per
kilowatt hour doubled, more or less, every
1.6 years.
And the things you do to improve performance
also almost invariably improve energy efficiency
of computing.
We're far from the theoretical limits but,
as all of you know, there are some technological
challenges that we're facing in the coming
years.
The biggest implications of these trends is
from mobile technologies, distributed technologies
that are small and cheap and connected and
the focus now, not just in the popular press
but in the engineering world, is a focus on
low power, figuring out ways to make tiny,
cheap, low power devices that can be self
powered and put in places that we never could
imagine putting them before.
And that's, as I said, a different set of
engineering challenges.
Some of the best engineering talent in the
world is now focusing on that area and I think
great things will come from that.
So, uh, my three year old, three and a half
year old twins have better Spanish pronunciation
than I do but, Viva la Revolucion!
This is where I wanna ask for your help.
So, if any of you are aware of technologies,
business models, companies doing interesting
work enabled by ultra low power, ultra high
efficiency, energy scavenging devices, I would
like to hear about it.
So come up after the talk, send me an email
and let me know what you're thinking.
With that I will say thanks to my funders
and coauthors and ask any quest-, answer any
questions that you may have.
>>male #3: Have you done any comparisons between
the rise in efficiency and the rise in the
total energy use of computers?
>>Jon Koomey: So the question is, have I looked
at the relationship between the rise in efficiency
and the rise in total energy use of computers?
The most recent work that I've done on total
energy use is in data centers alone.
So I haven't done careful analysis on the
whole IT picture.
That's, I think, what you're getting at, right?
Because as you have more and more distributed
devices there's more energy associated with
these different devices.
So back in 2000 or so, there were a couple
of guys running around talking about how the
internet was gonna use half of all electricity
in ten years and we did pretty careful analysis
to summarize for PCs and all office equipment
and data centers, everything else, the number
for the US was around three percent of all
electricity use.
My bet is that that's a little higher now
but it's probably still single digit percentage
because we're, what's happening is we're at
the same time as we're increasing our usage
of computing but we're also starting to shift
towards technologies that are more efficient.
So a shift away from CRT screens, shift towards
laptops, more computing being done on hand-held
devices.
So you have counter veiling trends that it's
clear that there are, that there is, we're
using a little more electricity for IT than
we did in 2000 but it's not exploding in the
same way as the amount of information services
is exploding.
>>Luiz Barroso: One of the, we're looking
at these from a technology standpoint, you
sort of understand the economics better than
I do, Chuck Moore, another Moore not that
one, an architect at AMD used to talk about
this virtual cycle in computing which new
technology was created, that created devices
that were totally amazing and those devices
had a market value that allowed you to get
a lot of money to invest in new technology,
right, and this kept going forward.
At the time that he mentioned that at first,
he was concerned that, then being in the PC
business, that perhaps computers are fast
enough and therefore this virtual cycle would
end due to the fact that it was harder and
harder to create new value on top of what
they had already at that point.
What do you, what do you think of that?
>>Jon Koomey: So the question relates to the
idea that somehow as you, you reach kind of
a saturation in the performance of the, I'm
sorry, the need for people's, for computing
for people that the PC business in particular
would be effected by this.
That's one way to-
>>Luiz Barroso: That's one example.
>>Jon Koomey: That's one example.
So what I think you're seeing is devices that
are coming closer and closer to tasks.
So the PC is a general purpose device and
I think we have saturated, for most folks,
you know, my mom using email, she doesn't
need much more performance, right?
But what we do need is distributed performance,
distributed computing that is much closer
to the actual tasks that we're trying to perform
and can help us make decisions in real time.
You aren't gonna carry your desktop computer
with you all around but you have your phone.
So I think, I don't think it's going to result
in a slower innovation path or less value,
it's just gonna be value to different companies.
Companies who are able, then, to create innovation
for particular sets of users, for particular
kinds of tasks and deliver that innovation
to folks who need it.
So, a strange example, I saw a scale that
is connected via Wi-Fi to the internet.
>>Luiz Barroso: I have that.
>>Jon Koomey: You have that scale.
[Laughter]
>>Jon Koomey: Okay.
So this is a very interesting thing because
you, how much do you think a scale costs?
Just a normal scale.
>>female #1: 20 bucks.
>>Jon Koomey: 20 bucks, 30 bucks.
How much do you think they sell these scales
for?
>>Luiz Barroso: $100.
>>Jon Koomey: $100.
Okay, so, here is an example where, this is
pretty much the same device, it has a very,
you know, some chips, a few other little things
that maybe cost 5 or 10 bucks but they're
delivering customer value that makes you wanna
pay 100 bucks for it.
So you can't lie about your weight anymore.
But you have, you know, automatically it comes
up to the Cloud and it, you know, creates
a nice graph for you of what's happening over
time.
So I think that's an example where the customer
value that you're creating is because you're
really close to their need for information
and their decision and that's a different
thing from creating a general purpose computing
device.
I think we're gonna really focus much more
on that need for specific, focus on specific
tasks.
>>male #4: Yes, hi, I had a quick question
for you.
Could you comment on the trends in the chemical
batteries?
>>Jon Koomey: Chemical?
>>male #4: Batteries, cause I can see that
there's this like, on a log scale you have
this straight line for computing power increasing
over the decades but what's been the situation
with the batteries innovation in chemical
batteries?
>>Jon Koomey: OK, so the question is on the
rate of innovation in chemical batteries and
obviously the trends are, the changes are
much slower.
So we're starting to see people, and that's
gonna be part of the case study work that
I'm doing is to show those trends as well
over time, for batteries.
But, much, much slower and what, because the
computing trends improved so fast we're getting
now into the regime where current battery
chemistries can allow us to create really
small devices.
So we're getting a little bit better and as
people focus more on, for example, lithium
ion batteries and other similar technologies
for cars, we're starting to see real R and
D going into this in a way, you know, 40 years
ago there just wasn't that kind of R and D
going into batteries in the, at the same scale.
So I think there will be improvements there
but because the computing trends improved
so fast that's where most of the change is
gonna happen and it will start to bring more
and more applications into the realm of feasibility
for certain battery chemistries.
You're also starting to see people playing
around with flow batteries and fuel cells
and other things like that and so, I visited
MIT about a month and a half ago and one of
their scientists there showed me a device
they were gonna use for a space mission.
The only way they could get it to operate
for 5 years was a little fuel cell.
No battery technology was gonna do it and
so I think that there's certainly a trend,
you know, there's ways to improve battery
chemistry stuff but really the action is on
the electronic side.
>>male #5: So, I think you mentioned this
a little bit already but I was wondering if
you could say more about the, the trends that
we've seen in both aggregate and energy consumption
and the use of electronics and computers and
things like that as a relative percentage
of that and also the trade-offs in energy
consumption we see as more and more things
go virtual and go online and go to the Cloud.
Do you have data or research on either of
those things?
Like, I'm thinking for example in my home,
you know, I've got a lot more gadgets now
than I used to but the total power I use in
my house hasn't changed that much over time
and the bulk of it is, you know, goes to lighting
and appliances and things like that that are
completely different technologies.
>>Jon Koomey: So you have a bunch of things
going on there, so the question relates to
what have been these kinds of aggregate trends
in total electricity use and how does that
relate to our increased use of competing technology?
>>male #5: Right.
>>Jon Koomey: So, my best guess now is we're
talking single digit percent in the US for
total direct electricity used by IT equipment
but what you're seeing is, let's call it five
or six percent.
You've got that five or six percent of direct
electricity used for computing, couple percent
of that is data centers, but we also have
the other 95 percent which is being effected,
in many cases, by the IT equipment.
And you also have the rest of fuel consumption,
non electricity consumption, that could potentially
affect it as well.
So I think it's important to track the total
electricity used by IT, I think it's something
I've done, you know, something I've done for
a long time, I think it's important to do
but I think it's also important to try to
understand the effect of that IT on the rest,
the other 95 percent.
And that, to me, is the more interesting question.
So one example that I did, that I worked on
recently relates to a trade-off between buying
music on a CD versus downloading it and we
found that even in the best case for CD, sending
a CD compared to the worst case for downloading,
that it was still a 40 percent savings and
it's much likely to be in emissions, it's
much likely to be more than that.
So I think that it's important to start to
do more and more case studies like that to
understand these systemic effects because
direct electricity use, while it's more important,
it's not something we should be getting very
excited about because it's, at the end of
the day it's a pretty good use for the electricity,
in my view.
And on the data center side, you've got, let's
just call it 90 percent of data center floor
space is in house data centers in companies
whose main business is not computing.
It's, in general, very, very inefficient.
Utilization for servers of five to 15 percent,
a number of comatose servers not doing anything
but still using electricity, 20, 25, 30 percent
of the servers.
Huge inefficiencies there as there'll be a
shift more towards Cloud implementations there'll
be actually a reduction, increase in the efficiency
of producing those services as a reduction
in energy use.
So there's a huge potential for improvements
in data centers simply by shifting towards
a more efficient way of delivering the services.
So there's a lot of moving parts in this but
you're asking the right question I just think
the focus really needs to be on the other
95 percent and what the IT can be doing for
that.
>>male #6: When you mentioned five to six
percent usage by IT does that count the cooling
of those data centers or is it-
>>Jon Koomey: Yes, so the two percent-
>>male #6: so it's the total.
>>Jon Koomey: for data centers, two percent
for data centers includes everything related
to the infrastructure.
>>male #6: Okay, thank you.
>>Jon Koomey: The cooling, fans, pumps, everything
like that.
>>male #7: I had a similar question about
your data set that span many decades, did
you try to make, include in some way the cooling
or other overhead outside of the, you know,
the ENIACs and the-
>>Jon Koomey: So that's a good question, actually,
for this particular set of trends I did not
include cooling cause I wanted to get at the
characteristics of the IT equipment itself.
>>male #7: I wonder if the effective efficiency
doubling time for some periods of history
actually been shorter.
>>Jon Koomey: it's a good question.
I think that there's been changes in the way
that services have been delivered that would
be hard to track but I agree that it's something
that should be looked at.
>>male #8: Have you looked at the delivered
computation as opposed to the computational
efficiency?
In particular what I'm thinking of is the
software efficiency, now, 20 years ago I had
a Window Manager that was about as responsive
as the one today but it takes way more instructions.
>>Jon Koomey: Yeah, so the question relates
to looking at software efficiency as opposed
to hardware and this is to me, actually this
is a fascinating area because in the past
we've mainly thought of performance as a question
of hardware.
We said Intel will give us or AMD will give
us more performance, we just don't have to
worry about our code.
Well I think that's changing particularly
as the need for parallelism, you know, you
have a lot of cords you have to change your
software that's very important.
It turns out that there are big potential
gains there.
There are some folks at LBL that have looked
at what's called code design of software and
hardware.
This is a term that comes from the embedded
system space but they're starting to apply
into the super computer space because when
they came to Steve Chu when he was the director
of the lab there and said our new super computer
is gonna use 200 megawatts and they said,
Steve Chu said, "No, go back and redesign
it" and they started to look at ways to co-design
the software and hardware and they were finding,
you know, tours of magnitude improvement in
the efficiency just because they optimized
the software and the hardware together to
attack certain kinds of problems.
They were gonna see a lot more of that and
it's really true, I think everyone here has
a story about, you know, we're doing the same
basic thing using a whole lot more cycles.
And part of what I think goes on is that the
costs of inefficient code are not being brought
to bear on the people who are designing it
and as soon as you can get to the place where
someone selling data centers services is able
to give that information to the people using
the services, when we get to that point, then
you're gonna start to see much more optimization.
We're not there yet but you can imagine it
being done to technology that exists today
and that's where I think we need to get to
so that people actually understand the true
total cost of a computing cycle when they're
using it and then they'll change their behavior.
Thanks to all of you.
[Applause]